Uh, one of the real downsides to having a
president like Donald Trump that throws so
many norms and conventions to the wind and
acts in the childish, immature and erratic
way that he does is that it can help normalize
or rehabilitate former presidents who also
did things that aren't particularly good.
And I've been really careful to avoid this
with George W. Bush.
So for the last two and a half years when
I've pointed out, wow, Trump is going beyond
even the craziness of George W. Bush in many
ways.
I'm always sort of careful to remind you that
we don't want to incorrectly rehabilitate
George W Bush's image.
Bush was a terrible ignorant neo-con as a
president, but he had some common decency
in some basic human ways that Donald Trump
just completely lacks.
And in the same way, I had many disagreements
with Barack Obama on policy during the eight
years of Barack Obama's presidency.
Obama's escalation of the drone war, Obama's
war on whistle blowers, Obama's inability
to make real progress on immigration, uh,
Obama starting from to make a position on
healthcare reform.
There's a very long list of disagreements
I had on policy with Barack Obama, but Barack
Obama was an intelligent, thoughtful, and
to my belief, fundamentally genuine person
to the extent that you can know those characteristics
about a person when you see them through the
media and through their actions as president
of the United States.
And Barack Obama recently wrote a letter in
response to the shootings in El Paso and in
Dayton, Ohio, and it is just a glaring reminder
of what we're lacking right now, which is
a president who behaves like an adult and
Donald Trump couldn't take it and was so triggered
by Barack Obama that even though Obama didn't
mention him in his letter, Trump immediately
took to Twitter to insult Barack Obama.
Now this is no Obama love letter.
Okay?
It's just something that reminded me of what
we've lost with Donald Trump is president.
Let's take a look at the letter, which most
importantly for me points out some of the
obvious things that a president should be
saying, but Donald Trump is not Obama saying,
quote, Michelle and I grieve with all the
families in El Paso in Dayton, who endured
these latest mass shootings.
Even if details are still emerging, there
are a few things we already know to be true.
First, no other nation on earth comes close
to experiencing the frequency of mass shootings
that we see in the United States.
No other developed nation tolerates the levels
of gun violence that we do.
Every time this happens, we're told that tougher
gun laws won't stop all murders, that they
won't stop every deranged individual from
getting a weapon and shooting innocent people
in public places.
But the evidence shows that they can stop
some killings.
They can save some families from heartbreak.
We are not helpless here, and until all of
us stand up and insist on holding public officials
accountable for changing our gun laws, these
tragedies will keep happening.
Second, while the motivations behind these
shootings may not yet be fully known, there
are indications that the El Paso shooting
follows a dangerous trend, troubled individuals
who embrace racist ideologies and see themselves
obligated to act violently to preserve white
supremacy like the followers of Isis and other
foreign terrorist organizations.
These individuals may act alone, but they've
been radicalized by white nationalists websites
that proliferate on the internet.
That means that both law enforcement agencies
and internet platforms need to come up with
better strategies to reduce the influence
of these hate groups.
But just as important, all of us have to send
a clarion call and behave with the values
of and diversity that should be the hallmark
of our democracy.
We should soundly reject language coming out
of the mouths of any of our leaders that feeds
a climate of fear and hatred or normalizes
racist sentiments.
Leaders who demonize those who don't look
like us or suggest that other people, including
immigrants, threaten our way of life or refer
to other people as subhuman or imply that
America belongs to just one certain type of
people.
Such language isn't new.
It's been at the root of most human tragedy
throughout history here in America and around
the world.
It's at the root of slavery and Jim Crow,
the Holocaust, the genocide in Rwanda and
ethnic cleansing in the Balkans.
It has no place in our politics and our public
life, and it's time for the overwhelming majority
of Americans of goodwill, of every race and
faith and political party to say as much,
clearly and unequivocally.
This is just obvious contexts that's missing.
When we hear Republicans and Trump talk about
this, no other country has these gun violence
problems.
No other country country has the resistance
caused by stupid but well-funded talking points
that we do.
And secondly, whether it's isis or these right
wing terrorists, it's the same mechanism of
radicalization and we have to call it out
as such, and we have to call it terrorism
in all cases.
And by the way, just dripping from the letter
is actual empathy and Constellation for people.
Something that Donald Trump seems fundamentally
just unable to achieve.
Instead of having the instincts of going to
Puerto Rico after a hurricane and shooting
rolls of paper towels like basketball's like
a game.
And Donald Trump was so triggered by this
letter, which doesn't even mention him by
name, that he immediately went to Twitter
to insult Barack Obama with a quote from Fox
and friends quoting Brian Kilmeade on Fox
and friends saying, did George Bush ever condemn
President Obama after Sandy Hook?
President Obama had 32 mass shootings during
his reign.
Not many people said Obama's out of control.
Mass shootings were happening before the president
even thought about running for president.
Now there's a number of problems with that,
including that there have been hundreds and
hundreds of mass shootings under Donald Trump.
But more importantly, Obama didn't even mention
Trump in his letter, and Obama was trying
to make changes, which he couldn't get done
as simple as background checks.
And this goes to Donald Trump's insecurity
more than anything else.
And there's two sides to this.
On the one hand, just being able to speak
and write in complete sentences distinguishes
Barack Obama from Donald Trump in really important
ways.
But the substance of the letter is also something
that Donald Trump is unwilling or unable to
put together.
I've said before, money can't buy class.
It's never been more clear than right now.
But the problem is that the longer Trump is
in office, the longer that this becomes more
and more okay.
It shouldn't be startling to us to see, oh,
a president that can speak coherently and
isn't personally attacking political enemies
on Twitter and is thinking big picture about
social and political issues.
It does surprise us.
It's notable even for me and for people in
our audience.
Trump has been normalized to a great degree
and every day that he's in office becomes
more normal.
In a sense, there has to be a purge that's
bigger than just getting rid of Trump.
Having people like Jared and Ivanka in positions
of power has been normalized.
Having advisors like Kellyanne Conway has
been normalized.
Treating our allies with disrespect as some
show of manhood has been normalized.
It all has to be purged.
It only starts with getting Trump out in November
of 2020 let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at [inaudible] pacman.
The show
is
on
Twitter at David Pacman